Many of you I see when
I walk across the campus
every morning.
As I said, until today
I've been a volunteer,
but I've enjoyed walking
in with some of you
and talking about what
you do for the university
and how great this place is.
Right now I'm
going to invite you
all into Old Main for
refreshments, and let's go in
and enjoy a good
time of fellowship.
Thank you all for being here.
So let's go inside.
Take me at my word.
I am going to be out on campus.
I'm going to be involved.
That's Amy's worst
nightmare, because she's
trying to keep me on schedule
and keep me in my lane.
But as I've told
everyone, my favorite time
is start meetings about
7:00 o'clock at night,
because the only
time limit on that
is 7 o'clock in the morning
getting back to the office.
Hello.
I'm in the college
ofr agriculture.
Been there for 40 years.
Wnat to welcome you.
Wow.
Thank you very much
for doing that.
You must have started
in junior high.
'76.
Wow.
I really want to be able to
meet everybody who came out here
today.
And as you guys know who've
seen me around campus,
I will be out there.
Please come up and speak to me.
It's incredible the number
of people who've just come up
to me and told me their story.
And there's so many
great stories here.
So excited you're here.
Good.
Well, I didn't think
anybody was going to come.
But this is great.
Thank you each and
every one of you
for what you do
for the university.
We're only as strong
as our weakest link.
And everybody here
has an important job
that you do every day.
I wanted you to know that
tribal nations are very, very
excited that you're
our president,
so there will be many more
opportunities for engagement.
So thank you for being here
and bear down to move up.
[CHEERS, APPLAUSE]